this is a Cajun chicken alfredo and it
was so good I'm testing out Tasty's new
AI Bata Tui and asked it to give me a
recipe that'll make my wife fall in love
with me all over again and this is it
let's get into it let's season our
chicken breast with garlic powder onion
powder salt and cajun give me a nice mix
then we're gonna sear it on each side
until you get a nice crust and take it
out we're gonna add our turkey sausage
cook until Brown remove add a shallot
and cook until fragrant then we're gonna
come in with some heavy cream season
with more Cajun give it a nice mix hit
with some fresh parsley some Parmesan
you guys should know always salt that
pasta water added back your turkey
sausage which is nice and thick add your
pasta and give it a mix folks help us
make butter to eat even better by
downloading the tasty app and testing it
out with us